[Music]
19 years ago Chuck Berman was murdered
focus quickly turned to Warren cave and
that's where I come in I helped seal
Warren's fate with a series of articles
is there an innocent man in prison and
did I need that charge I'd like you to
reconsider
[Music]
Octavia's character poppy has a podcast
called reconsidered and it's very
fitting for this case because we are
reconsidering warren caves guilt or
innocence and were reeling what actually
happened in the crime she decides to
start a podcast and now old skeletons
have been dug up i'm going to find your
father was unaccounted for at the time
of ted Berman's murder it rides the wave
of the true crime podcast craze that we
all enjoy it's exploring what happens to
the real people involved in these
stories that we get a kick out of
discussing around the water cooler
poppy chose a podcast as a medium
because it is the path of least
resistance and you can reach the masses
his podcast about your family has people
talking the podcast is the thing that
ties us to her and also her emotional
thinking of where her characters at and
what she believes and how she expresses
the doubts and conviction she has that's
what i think is so great about this show
and podcasts like this show and true
crime dramas is that it just keeps you
on your toes we're our own detectives we
want to be the ones solving the crime
it's getting to explore our greatest
fears as human beings in a way that
feels completely safe I'm poppy Parnell
thank you for listening
you
you